let's go now from talking about Jeff
Flake in the context of Roy Moore to the
RNC and Donald Trump in the context of
the Alabama Senate race back on November
20th I reported to you that the
Republican National Committee had pulled
out of Roy Moore or better said maybe
that's not the right way to say they
pulled support from Roy Moore's campaign
after multiple allegations of more
having sexually assaulted women and
girls
they removed money they removed people
from the December 12th special election
where Doug Jones is the Democratic
opposition to Republican Roy Moore the
RNC has now quietly returned their
support to Roy Moore they got I guess
some PR benefit from having pulled their
support initially just as the polling
was bottoming out for Roy Moore now
Donald Trump has sort of endorsed or has
endorsed Roy Moore it's been a couple of
weeks since the latest allegations and
now that the Republican Party realized
wait a second we prefer the child sex
assault er instead of the Democrat the
RNC is fully back in helping Roy Moore
and in in Alabama at Indiana they have
absolutely no shame Donald Trump a
couple days ago tweeted his support for
Roy Moore saying Democrats refusal to
give even one vote for massive tax cuts
is why we need Republican Roy Moore to
win in Alabama we need his vote on
stopping crime illegal immigration
border wall military pro-life VA judges
second amendment and more no to Jones a
Palouse pelosi schumer puppet and indeed
the RN c-- is back in roy more they are
now putting money and staff behind his
campaign now what's the on the record
explanation from the RNC we don't have
one we know that a couple weeks ago RNC
chairwoman
Ronna Romney McDaniel said quote the
recent allegations against judge Moore
are deeply troubling he should step
aside if there is any truth to them at
all we know that there is still no
reason to question any of the
allegations and we know that the RN C
that an RN C official confirmed to The
Daily Beast that yes they are back to
supporting Roy Moore but we know nothing
else other than what we know about the
Republican
party which is that they're the opposite
of everything that they claim to be the
Republican Party claims to be about
family values and very clearly this
example tells us that they're not the
Republican Party claims to be about
small government except when they want
to enforce their religious and social
ideas at which point they have no
problem with government getting very
very big they claim to be about fiscal
conservatism except when it's tax cuts
for the rich that explode the debt Jeff
Flake said as I told you earlier in
today's program country over party and
that's why he donated a hundred bucks to
doug jones against his party colleague
republican roy more the party overall is
the party of party over country and
that's reflected in their support for
Trump in the 2016 election and it's
reflected in their support for Roy Moore
in this special election and it's
absolutely and totally pathetic I think
they're just following the polls which
requires absolutely no integrity I mean
when it looked like Roy Moore was a
longshot
soon after the allegations broke
obviously they're going to pull funding
because you're just taking so much
political risk now that he's catching up
and perhaps leading why not go along
with it he has a chance and that tells
us what that none of these decisions
have anything to do with ethics or
morality or family values or
conservatism or what's right or what's
wrong it merely has to do with political
posturing and the bottom line is they
prefer the alleged serial child sex
abusers to the Democrat that there's no
simpler way to say it that's exactly
what it is more money more problems well
yes in some way and I guess at this
point we have a major major problem for
the Republican Party around the country
if indeed this backfires and I really
really hope that it does today's program
is made possible in part by Blue Sky
binary have you heard of blockchain
blockchains the new trend in technology
and on the internet and too many people
are not aware of both the power and the
risks of blockchain technology some
people think it's too complicated it's
too difficult to get into so people stay
away and they miss out on the
opportunity to really know about the
opportunities that blockchain presents
but it doesn't have to be this way and
the solution is the blue sky binary
blockchain academy blue sky binary is a
leading financial education and
technology company and they're turning
their attention to blockchain they've
launched their blockchain academy to
complement their other successful
training programs and they've created a
blockchain education course for
beginners and active crypto users alike
and in this score course students will
be taken through a series of topics
which ultimately will deliver a solid
understanding of how blockchain works
and help the student realize the current
and potential future uses of block tank
blockchain technology we've talked about
some of these on the bonus show and on
the program and the course includes
video on-demand online tests access to a
community of traders and blockchain
enthusiasts who exchange knowledge and
experiences and you can register now to
get a 3 day free trial that includes
access to the first module of the course
for you to evaluate the overall quality
of the program and afterwards it's 49
and 99 a month you can stop and resume
at any point checkout blue sky
binary.com
slash david to sign up today